this is a typical question right now
that once a find the equation of a
tangent or they'll say find the tangent
by which they mean finds its equation
find it just saying look I drew it there
it is okay so when they say find the
teacher this is what they mean and
they'll say find the equation of the
tangent to such as such a curve function
at a particular point okay now
occasionally if then you're maybe give
me grumpy to you rather than say at and
they'll name a point they'll say when
and then they'll supply you an x value
right now there's not really a material
difference between these two questions
it just adds one more step which is that
you'd have to take this and then just
chuck in there and it out comes a
y-value okay so really they're the same
question one length difference okay how
do you do this I've got a point minus
one zero
right there on the curve okay - now I
have a point that goes through all I
need in terms of extra information is
the gradient at that point and that's
what the whole derivative is about so
you're gonna have to take this because
it's in terms of Y is rather than EPS
and so on I would say dy or DX and this
stage you're just gonna quickly march
through fresh pencils and get derivative
out now we've actually seen and I wonder
if you can think of why we looked at um
we looked at why I can't x squared right
and we do this through first principles
that dy on DX is 2x
now what's interesting is what's you
march through first principles with this
if you use this as your starting point
you find surprise surprise the same
derivative now why would that be the
case - it's just looking at the okay
they're the same what does that mean
yeah ma
very good the difference between this
graph and this graph is a vertical shift
right but if for example you compare any
point on to you like say on it I say x
equals zero
can you see from this graph to the other
because all we've done is move it up and
down
how is the gradient changing enter it's
not it's still the same the gradient for
this and for this and for anything
that's just off by a constant of some
description it's just moving up and down
so it's greedy to still gonna behave
exactly the same way so once you have
that all you need to do is take the
actual next day that they've supplied
you so I would say when x equals minus
one please that's a scoop on that line
by the way I know no what are you like
that's what I have to do so I'm just
gonna say dy or DX equals negative two
you go straight from this line to this
line bad idea okay the reason why is
because just so the equation stopped
coming out of nowhere where are they
coming from what's the logic that binds
them all together right you're gonna
need some serious help when you've got
many many different points and you've
got this dy DX and this dy DX and you
have like four different ones flying
around which ones which and what do they
mean so this I have you as really
important to write down even though it's
not part of the the working is part of
my logic got point got a great yet think
back to linear functions what I'm gonna
put into point gradient form right Y
minus y1 and outside of X minus x1 yep
and from there it's just a substitution
yeah let's just quickly do it together Y
minus M
X minus negative 1 y equals -2 X plus
minus minus minus minus 2 okay yeah
now you just quickly check you somebody
this was not the question but it's easy
to verify right minus 2 X so it's
decreasing as you'd expect and you're
hitting the axis at negative 2 which is
down there I'm pretty close yes it's
really one of the right things about
this is very easy to verify if you've
got something on the right track or not
okay so if you have written that down or
you're checking against another question
you're like how did I lay it out okay
your important bits are finally gradient
substituting it in insane it should
doing that it's really important this is
as simple as it gets there will be lots
more pieces of information that we'll
add on to this as we attempt more
complicated questions so you better say
what you're doing before an equation
just you know don't you know while the
creating appeared don't do that say
where they come from and then how comes
the equation of your teacher